las quinielas apuntaban al presidente de
Ucrania bolodimir selenski pero
finalmente el premio Nobel de la paz
2022 ha sido otorgado a activistas
posoviéticos como el bielorruso Álex
vialiatsky y dos organizaciones
defensoras de los Derechos Humanos como
Memorial de Rusia y el centro para las
libertades civiles de Ucrania
durante muchos años han promovido el
derecho a criticar El Poder y proteger
los derechos fundamentales de los
ciudadanoski fue detenido en julio del
año pasado en una campaña gubernamental
contra opositores ha vigilado la
represión del presidente de belarús
Alexander lukashenko especialmente
durante las protestas del verano de 2020
la opositora exiliadas beldana Vizcaya
valoró el premio desde París Este es un
reconocimiento para toda la gente que
está sacrificando su libertad y sus
vidas por belarus y sus países Memorial
es una iniciativa ciudadana surgida en
el final de La Unión soviética su
objetivo ha sido investigar crímenes de
la urso más recientes como los de
chechenia la organización fue suspendida
en Rusia tras el inicio de la guerra en
Ucrania este Nobel es para todos los que
están vivos los que ya se fueron los que
están en la cárcel y los que fueron
asesinados por último está el centro
para las libertades civiles una
organización ucraniana independiente de
Derechos Humanos entre sus otras
funciones también destaca combatir la
corrupción Cuando comenzó la agresión a
gran escala obviamente no nos quedamos
de brazos cruzados organizamos un equipo
de Defensores de la ley que documentó
activamente los crímenes de guerra
el premio se entrega en plena guerra en
Ucrania y en el día del 70 cumpleaños
del presidente ruso Vladimir Putin
Aunque el comité del Nobel negó que el
galardón Sea contra este o su homólogo
bielorruso Alexander Lu